euro von innsbruck
die minibar sowie suppen
hallo hier rezeption
wir haben prominente gäste nein das war
jetzt gar nicht anzüglich gemein zu
heißen die wirklich obwohl er beide
frauen sind seltsam sonja glass kommt
aus hamburg
valeska steiner ist von hier aus zürich
gestern haben die mich glatt
mitgenommenen zu einem kleinen club da
haben die dann zum ersten mal die songs
von ihrem neuen album gespielt
der hier heißt hotel sind spezielle
atmosphäre machen sondern wirklich zum
nachtisch oder zwei und nachher wieder
mitreißt und und ich habe es zunächst
fühle mich so eines zimmers und sich
fragt was ich schon da passieren machen
und wieder weg das zimmer nebenan
ich habe sie gefragt was sie denn für
vorliegen haben im hotel als alter hase
vom empfang darf man ja schon mal
nachfragen
deswegen versuche ich immer sie mir ein
bisschen zu eigen zu machen und und und
mag mich so einzuleben schnell in das
zimmer sozusagen und deswegen häng ich
auch meistens das don t stop sanitär
damit niemand rein kommt und mein bett
macht unterschiedlich wie ich so gerne
aber nicht alles wieder super und
aufgrund
schulz tui sowie vor
nach dem 2
dister
mit
schön zu erfahren was die so alles sehen
oft uhr kann man sich ja kaum vorstellen
das war deprimierend flughafen
als sie dann diese schätzung von 2011
gespielt haben hat es bei mir klick
gemacht der herbert grönemeyer hat sie
entdeckt groß rausgebracht
sie tourten um die ganze welt
wir haben so das gefühl wir haben uns
auf eine reise begeben die dann immer
länger oder sozusagen
sie war nicht so lange geplant für uns
ist es ein riesengeschenk eigentlich
dass wir zu reisen können mit unserer
musik und dass die musik ebenso
universell ist und uns mit mit menschen
und orten verbindet wo wir ich halte
jetzt wieder meine platz an der
rezeption die girls ich meine reisen
bald weiter
was dann keine ahnung hoffentlich bringt
sie wieder so schöne hotel geschichten
nach hause